in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
and I'm with dr. Oliver Peters his head
of the memory clinic here at the charity
in Berlin and he's doing research in the
field of dementia thanks for inviting me
into a clinic but if it is what do you
think about vegetables fruit and fish to
prevent dementia healthy nutrition might
help to prevent dementia you will not
prevent any way but it might help
somehow yes so you reduce the risk
forgetting it exactly you might decrease
the risk to suffer from dementia as a GP
I always time a patient to stick to a
Mediterranean diet or prevent diabetes
or heart disease and has diabetes
something in common with dimension that
the the nutritional advice is basically
the same there are parallels in both
diseases in that way that healthy
nutrition might help to keep your
vessels clean to improve the the brain
with with blood and an oxygen but yeah
there's that there's there's a power in
this and other other risk factors in the
development of dementia yeah there are
other kinds of dementia they develop by
chronic neurodegeneration the most
common diseases Alzheimer's dementia
this is a complete different thing a lot
of patients who have dementia and are
depressed as well is depression and
dementia in any way related yeah there
is a relation in in both ways on
and depression might increase the risk
to develop I mention on the other hand
it is known that in many cases
depression might be the earliest sign of
dementia so there is a close
relationship between both disease we got
a lot of questions over the Internet one
of them is from Sandra Palermo from
Italy he says that vitamin D and
antioxidants are known that they can
protect the brains any truth to that in
that way that if you suffer from
malnutrition then you should take
vitamins to add those who are not enough
in your body but if you you have a
normal nutrition then you don't need
these additional vitamins so there's no
additional use if you just top up your
vitamins above the northern level
exactly samara from tunisia wants to
know is sugar dangerous to the plane the
brain is metabolizing high amount of
sugar that we that we used and but there
is no hint that too much sugar might be
delirious to the brain it's one thing to
try to protect your brain from damages
and 2 to suffer from dementia later on
in life but what if there are early
signs of dementia can you change this
with a right nutrition know that there's
there's no hint that you can do that if
this is really the beginning of a
dementia alzheimer type you may not be
able to to change that by just changing
your lifestyle so it's more like having
the right lights lifestyle during life
to decrease the risk exactly languid
look dr. Peters and Alzheimer's disease
is the most common form of dementia can
you protect yourself from Alzheimer
disease with a healthy lifestyle as well
you may do something that is helpful
also in
regarde antennas disease this is because
Adams there's almost no pure Alzheimer's
disease there's always also vessel
disease and this is the part of dementia
that you can where you can do something
the core of Alzheimer's disease is new
generation and this is what you to our
best knowledge cannot influence by our
last time Alzheimer's is very hard to
treat that there are new medication
currently used the so called antibodies
as a therapy and how are they working
there are symptomatic treatments already
available and this is important to
mention that at this point but we cannot
cure the disease and this is a
difference we can just improve the
symptoms so far our ultimate goal is to
to cure the disease and what we think or
what we can imagine is that by giving
antibodies every month we can improve
the immune system and by this remove the
so called plaques that are most likely
the cause for the disease and by this we
might stop the progression of the
disease and when do you have to start
therapy when the first symptoms appear
full-blown dementia is too late for this
approach we have to we have to give the
antibodies as early as possible nowadays
we we are doing this in very early
dementia stages but we can also imagine
that this has to be done when only the
earliest signs can be detected either in
the cerebral spinal fluid or by imaging
methods how do you detect the early
signs or it just takes some fluid out of
the body and exactly you can you can
examine the the Selva spinal fluid or
you can
use new imaging techniques amyloid
imaging is this call and this is a
nuclear medicine technique where you
visualize the plaques that are the cause
of disease but what kind of patients
would you would you say that they have
to come to you into your clinic and get
their self check for the risk of outside
normally the rule is that everybody who
suffers from memory problems for at
least six months and a caregiver also
observes this problems then you should
go to a memory clinic and examine what's
behind this to do prevention you might
do this in clinical programs where you
go to specialized memory clinics and
examine the Selva spinal fluid without
having any symptoms just if you think
that you have the risk to develop
dementia this is what we are already
doing today their research teams all
over the world working for them proper
treatment or prevention of outside so
how long will it take until it's problem
solved this is an extremely difficult
question nobody knows in the end but we
could imagine that in probably two or up
five years we will see the first new
treatments that maybe lay the disease
onset and the disease progression
you